D-DAD? DAD?
DAD!
- HEY, WHAT'S WRONG, MAN?
- I WAS HAVING A NIGHTMARE.
- OH, AGAIN?
WHAT, YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT?
- I MISS MOMMY.
- HEY, I KNOW.
I KNOW.
IT'S--HEY, ME TOO.
ME TOO, PAL.
- [sniffling]
- COME HERE, MAN.
- [sobbing]
- IT'S ALL RIGHT.
HEY, IT'S OKAY.
IT'S GONNA BE OKAY.
SHH, SHH, SHH.
- I JUST DON'T WANT ANYTHING
TO EVER HAPPEN TO YOU.
- HAPPEN TO ME?
HEY, COME ON, MAN, AIN'T NOTHING
EVER GONNA HAPPEN TO ME.
- REALLY?
- Y-YEAH.
THAT'S WHAT I SAID.
SO, YES.
THAT, UM, NOTHING EVER GONNA
HAPPEN TO ME.
AMD YOU AIN'T NEVER
GONNA HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT NOTHING
HAPPENING TO ME.
- BUT--BUT--WHAT IF--
WHAT IF YOU GOT HIT BY A CAR
OR SOMETHING?
- THAT'S IMPOSSIBLE,
BECAUSE I WILL NEVER DIE,
S-SO I CAN'T...
DIE, NO MATTER WHAT.
- YOU CAN'T DIE?
BUT I THOUGHT
ALL HUMAN BEINGS DIED.
- THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S SCIENCE,
SO THAT'S TRUE.
BUT I AM LUCKY,
'CAUSE I AM NOT A HUMAN.
- YOU'RE NOT?
- I NEVER TOLD YOU ABOUT THIS?
- NO.
- HEY, YOU KNOW,
I'LL JUST LET IT OUT.
I'M FROM A PLANET CALLED
L-LA--THELONIOUS,
AND THE THING IS,
IT WAS BEING DESTROYED.
- OKAY.
- THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
MY--WAS--I WAS SENT DOWN
HERE IN--IN--
IN A CAPSULE TO EARTH
BY MY PARENTS.
- OH, LIKE SUPERMAN.
- SUPERMAN, YEP.
THAT IS WHAT
IT IS EXACTLY LIKE, EXCEPT--
OH, HERE'S THE THING
ABOUT MY VERSION.
ONLY ONE SUPERPOWER--
IMMORTALITY.
- OH.
- YEAH.
SO I'M TIRED.
DADDY'S TIRED.
CAN YOU--
LET'S GO TO SLEEP, OKAY?
- BUT I'M NOT GOING TO LIVE
FOREVER, RIGHT?
BECAUSE I'M ONLY HALF ALIEN.
[sobbing]
SO I'M GONNA DIE.
- MM-HMM, MM-HMM,
MM-HMM, MM-HMM.
YOU?
YOU--YOU RIGHT
ABOUT YOURSELF, EX--
BUT--
HA HA HA!
HERE IT IS.
THIS ONE SLIPPED MY MIND.
YOU CAN BUILD WITH ME
AN IMMORTALITY MACHINE
TO GIVE YOU WHAT I GOT
FROM THE REMNANTS
OF MY SPACECRAFT.
SO, YEAH.
- WOW.
- YOU GONNA BE IMMORTAL.
YOU GONNA BE IMMORTAL.
- DADDY, WHEN ARE WE GONNA GET
THE REMNANTS?
- TOMORROW.
- TOMORROW?
[gasps]
- GONNA GET THEM TOMORROW
DURING WORK.
HEY, YOU GOT ANYTHING
THAT LOOKS LIKE PARTS
OF A CRASHED SPACESHIP?
- DEAD MOM?
- MM-HMM.
RIGHT THIS WAY.
[applause]